now let's bring in major garrett now for
a look at how the white house and the
trump campaign intend to get through
this
major good morning to you as you know
the ramifications are enormous on this
what are you hearing from the white
house
and how are they handling it two
questions there well let's talk about
the national security implications
because that is one thing that we should
keep a very close eye on not only is
every reporter in washington trying to
figure out just how sick the president
is or might become
every adversary of the united states is
doing precisely the same thing
and our friendly intelligence agencies
are also trying to find out this is a
time
for maximum transparency from this white
house about this issue
to be as clear as possible about what
happened
when it happened and what the
president's condition is on a day-to-day
basis to reassure our friends
and also to send a very strong signal to
our foes
that the president can carry out the
business of the presidency
he is not in any way limited and the
work of the u.s government
under his watch goes on that is probably
the most dominant conversation going on
within the white house this morning
how to project that how to carry that
out and how to reassure
a somewhat nervous american public about
this news development but also
to send that message globally to those
who wish us well and wish us ill
now i would imagine a lot of people in
the white house are freaking out in in
terms of worrying about their own
exposure for instance it was reported in
paula's piece that hope hicks was was
tested positive
president trump knew that and did a
fundraiser in new jersey
so i'm wondering about the timeline and
who else might have been exposed to this
well this is going to be a classic
illustration of what i just spoke about
gail the transparency yeah you have to
as a white house explain
what the president knew when he knew it
and those that you are actually contra
contact tracing explain to the american
public how this process works
show what you're going to do explain all
the people you're going to contact and
all the people the president came in
contact with
to reassure not only them but explain
the american public how this process
works when someone in a very
important position contracts the virus
even though this president as we know
has lots of protections and has regular
testing that the fact that the virus got
in
got to him is indicative of how easily
it's transmitted
but also what you do once that
information is obtained
this is a window into this operation of
the white house and the president's
willingness or unwillingness to be
candid with the american public
will be part of the political discussion
not just about the coronavirus but his
own relationship to the american public
yeah the statement also said that he
intends to govern
while he is still in quarantine i'm
curious about how that's going to work
exactly and what will this mean for his
campaign
well let's talk about governing the
president can do that either from the
residents or from the oval office with
very limited
contact with people there'll be no
contact with people he can get lots of
memos
electronically he can make phone calls
and certainly anyone who's worked in
this white house gail knows that there's
many times the president communicates to
them on very important matters
via twitter on campaigning this will be
a significant drawback no more
fundraisers no more rallies
and if there are rallies in the future
what will they be conducted under will
be far more massive much more social
distancing there will have to be
and lastly they might have the
implications for the presidential
debates themselves the next presidential
debate october 15th
i'd have to believe that is somewhat up
in the air all right major a lot to
unpack there
of course we're all very concerned about
the president and first lady thank you
very much